- Le temps passe vite
à la ferme. Entre les traites
matin et soir, Christian Jutrass
prend soin de ses 90 bêtes,
de l'entreprise et de
ses champs.
Comme chaque année, les beaux
jours arrivent en même temps
que le boulot supplémentaire.
CHRISTIAN JUTRAS,
producteur laitier
it la première coupe,
après ça c'est les fumiers,
après les arrosages, après ça
les engrais, puis, t'sais,
tout, tout déboule.
- C'est sans parler de
son bétail, qui a besoin
de soins quotidiens.
Alors quand peut-il penser
prendre des vacances?
- Bien, moi, j'étais
pour vous dire, c'est quoi ça,
des vacances?
(rires)
- Chose certaine, de longuesvacs
envisageables. Mais Christian
se fait un devoir de prendre
des temps d'arrêt.
- On recule de 20 ans, bon bien,
c'était 7 jours sur 7.
On prenait aucune fin de
semaine. Et puis, j'ai instauré
ça. J'ai commencé avec 3 jours.
Mon père, il était pas fringuant
avec ça.
Des fois, juste lâcher un peu,
ça nous permet de prendre
un pas de recul puis voir :
Ah! Crime! Ça, on pourrait faire
ça comme ça à la place.
(conversation inaudible)
- Sa conjointe en sait quelque
chose. Éducatrice spécialisée,
elle oeuvre comme ressource
d'aide dans le milieu agricole.
L'enjeu de la santé mentale
est de moins en moins tabou,
mais les besoins restent grands.
HÉLEN BOURGOIN, éducatrice
spécialisée en milieu agricole
- Si on veut que nos animaux
puis notre métier aillent bien,
il faut commencer par nous,
le propriétaire, aller bien,
nous, l'agriculteur, aller bien.
Puis après tout va découler, là.
, c'est un peu ça
qu'on essaie de faire.
- Le Centre d'études sur
les coûts de production
en agriculture estime que
dans le domaine de la production
animale, les agriculteurs
travaillent environ 3000 heures
par année. C'est en moyenne
60 heures par semaine.
JEAN-FRANÇOIS DROUIN,
économiste, CECPA
- C'est une bonne charge
de travail, effect
On semble observer pour
les plus jeunes agriculteurs
un soucis plus grand
à prendre des vacances,à avoir ,
à se trouver un remplaçant.
- L'UPA remarque aussi
un changement de culture.
DENIS ROY, dir. Finances et
Main-d'oeuvre agricole, UPA
- Définitivement, c'est plus
valorisé de... une meilleure
conciliation production-vie
familiale, je vous dirais.
Puis on le sent d'ailleurs
dans le transfert d'entreprises.
- Malgré des avancées,
la détresse psychologique reste
présentede suicide
est plus élevé dans le secteur
agricole que dans le reste
de la société et ça touche
les hommes comme les femmes
dans toutes les productions
et toutes les régions.
Ici Kim Vermette,
Radio-Canada, Montréal